the royals tonight will commemorate
jackie robinson day on the 74 year
anniversary of robinson's major league
debut in which he broke baseball's color
barrier his number 42 was retired by
major league baseball in 1997
but for the 13th straight year all
players and on-field personnel will wear
number 42 today jacob junis has not
allowed a run in seven innings and he
has struck out nine six rbis for market
simeon popped up into shallow center
field
field is out from second base and
there's one down the batter now vladimir
guerrero jr
into right field so junis gets two
pop-ups a fly out
and a quick one two three top of the
first we found out about oh two hours
before the game tabby that anthony k
would make the start tonight for the
blue jays we'd had four hits
four runs scored and two stolen bases in
the angels series
that's off the end of the bat and past
the diving beshette
and the royals have their lead off man
on andrew benintendi does a good job of
staying in watch him go to left field
here whit runs and he does go to left
field and that is going to be down and
it's going to scoot past guriel
benintendi is going to get an rbi
he was thinking about three but
hits the brakes he'll settle for an rbi
double
and the royals lead one nothing
two batters into the bottom of the first
the shoulder stays closed a hitter has a
better opportunity to use the whole
field now that ball is middle and up but
because of his
ability in his form his left hand swing
he's able to hit that gap and not a good
route by guriel junior in left
the 2-2 to carlos santana weak ground
ball to third charged by biggio and a
bit wide of a throw but guerrero makes
the play santana retired and it's one to
nothing royals and with two outs of the
base is empty jay's down one to nothing
it'll be lourdes gorilla jr
it lines one sharply into left center
for a bay city and this is rowdy teles
and a swing and a miss he really fooled
him that time with a good hard slider
you've got to be impressed with the
velocity that we have seen so far from
kay
consistently 94-95 with the fastball
touching 96 at times and there's a 3-2
swing and a miss on a high fast ball two
down here's hunter dozier the right
fielder for the royals 2-2 and a good
sharp curve ball there from kay gets
dozier swinging marcus simeon here's the
2-2
in there strike three call
jacob junas sterling through three two
strikeouts only one base runner we head
to the bottom of ending number three now
nikki lopez and here's the pitch to
nikki he hits it to left guriel going
over dives he can't make the play that's
a fair ball
alberto is going to score easily nikki
around second racing to third and he
will
be safe there with a triple and the
royals lead two nothing royals are
really picking on lourdes
guriel out in left field it's two
nothing kc and now you have nikki lopez
at third with nobody out whit led off
the first inning with a single and
there's a ground ball to third and it's
kicked
by biggio and the royals lead three
nothing royals are hitting the ball hard
they can't control it after it leaves
their barrel that's a clank master he
didn't move his feet he was waiting for
it the ball will play you if you don't
play it see that he's just sitting there
with with his flat-footed and he knows
better that happens though in the game
arlo santana a guy who will take a walk
about as well as anybody in baseball the
o2 and a swing and a miss at a curveball
kay will strike out santana to win the
inning but the royals scored two more
and now lead three to nothing at the end
of three now kevin begio here's the
pitch swinging and a miss struck him out
on a good cutter and that is four
strikeouts for jacob junis we hit at the
bottom of the fourth inning blue jays
bring the infield in for
hunter dozier
and a line drive is into deep left
field and down into the corner so dozier
not only gets the run in
he'll be at second base with one out and
the royals have four runs in four
innings
outstanding job of being patient
working the 3-0 count
getting a good pitch to handle and not
missing it
looking good and anthony k will go three
and a third he'll depart dozier at
second base answer alberto reached with
an infield single leading off the third
inning
there's a line drive to left and that's
gonna be down
and the royals have their third double
in the inning alberto drives in dozier
and the royals lead five nothing in the
fourth not fooling anybody with a
breaking ball right to the bottom of the
strike zone at 74. alberto with a nice
little leg kick paul his hand gets down
in time excuse me his foot and the hands
come through the zone
nicely
same area he hit his home run in but he
stayed he kept it down in there and was
able to get some action witch singled
and scored the first run and whit lines
it past biggio
that was right at him
and the royals are going to get two more
so much for ball four how about another
double
what he was thinking about there but you
know you don't usually two hand the ball
to your right side like that but
he missed it
salvi he is grounded out to biggio at
third twice 02 and he got him
so perez strikes out and finally the
bottom of the fourth comes to a close
but
and the two two on the way and guriel
bounces one into right field for a base
hit so he is two for two so now rowdy
teles the d-h as he lines the ball to
right field solid contact for a base hit
up to second on the play
goes guriel back to the top of the order
marcus simeon 02 pitch waving a miss he
struck him out with the cutter make it
six for junis through five scoreless
frames glad he has flied out and doubled
so far tonight 1-1 lined softly into
right field a base hit for guerrero
and bechet will make the turn and come
to third
and now 81 pitches tonight jake newberry
is warmed up and ready to go and mike
matheny says
that's enough so here's joe panic who
came on at third base for bishop and he
lines one into right center field this
ball is going to get down and it'll get
all the way to the fence
the shet'll come in to score guerrero's
around third he'll score standing up
it'll be a two-run double for panic and
it's 7-2
royals pitchers have been very stingy
lately over their last seven games with
runners in scoring position just a 150
average that's a fastball out over the
plate a 1-1 pitch and the short swing by
panic is going to send it up the alley
in right center field for a couple of
rvis the two men on with one out for
rowdy teles
3-2 lined to right field and that's down
for a base hit
panic will come in to score goriel will
stop at third and it is seven to three
palacios with a ground out and a fly
ball to center tonight 2-1
lifts it in the air to center field
taylor having to go back on the ball
sets up underneath it goriel can tag and
he will come in to score on the
sacrifice fly that makes it seven to
four jansen is lined to left and struck
out
in the air shallow center whit goes out
he's calling for it
and he's got it so the blue jays get
back into the game with four hunter
dozier answer alberto and nikki lopez
and lifts the fly ball to left field
here comes gorielle diving and he's got
it
lourdes goriel jr with a terrific catch
out in left field it was hit off the end
of the bat so it wasn't hit that hard
but a good read by guriel and he's got
the speed to run it down for the first
down
and now man on for beau bashette
back to zimmer former college infielder
out at second and what a play at second
base by merrifield
to continue the double play vladi
tonight has a couple of hits he has
singled and doubled in addition to a fly
ball to right field
first pitch swinging and he crushes it
deep left center field it's hit a mile
guerrero with a home run his third on
the season and the blue jays are within
two boy the beauty of that swing dan on
top of the home run i'm looking at the
big picture right here he had a double
to left field he had a single to right
field and then weights on that breaking
ball from kyle zimmer and hits at the
center field it comes down to two on two
out vladimir guerrero jr is the hitter
got him
i don't know what you were so nervous
about hud we had him all the way oh man
i'll tell you what
he
swallowed that one like his daddy did
but uh you know if his dad would have
hit that though